the spread operator is three periods
this operator allows expressions to be
expanded in places where multiple
arguments elements or variables are
expected I will also talk about the rest
operator at the end of this video the
rest operator looks exactly like the
spread operator here are some common use
cases of the spread operator you can add
elements of an existing array into a new
array so here's the first array certs to
add and we have two array certifications
and ear algorithms and data structures
and front-end libraries and then also we
have our main array certifications and
we are going to add the search to add
into it so a responsive web design and
then right here is the spread operator
three dots inserts to add normally if
you put search to add here it would add
this complete array within the other
array but since we have the spread
operator right here it's going to just
add the elements of the array into the
new array so now we're going to have a
bunch of different elements including
the elements from the search to add if
we do console dot log we'll see that
they're all strings on this array
there's no array within the array and it
just lists all these different
certifications another use case is that
you can pass elements of an array as
arguments to a function so let's look at
this code right here so we have this
function add three numbers and there are
three arguments X Y Z and then it's just
going to add all those numbers together
and put and put it to the console now we
have an array called args with three
element 0 1 2 we're going to call the
add three numbers function but instead
of passing three individual arguments
like the function calls for we are going
to pass this array but we're going to
use the spread operator that's going to
spread out this array into the
individual elements so if we run that
it's just going to put three here and
add those numbers another thing to know
is if there is a fourth element and
in this array and we run that we're
still going to get three it's actually
going to ignore this fourth element in
the array when it spreads it out because
the function only calls for three items
okay the next thing is you can use it to
copy arrays so only put some code here
we're going to have your first array 1 2
3 and now this is how you would just
copy the array you would put the spread
operator and then ah the first array and
it's going to spread out the first to
what rate into the second array and
normally if you didn't copy the array
when you push a new item on to array 2
it would also push on to array 1 if they
were referencing the exact same thing
but in this example we're gonna show
that we're pushing on another item onto
the array and when we console that log
you will see the arrays are different
ar-ar-ar-ar-ar two are now different
because it did not push for onto the
exact same array they're completely
different arrays you can also use the
spread operator to concatenate arrays or
just put two different arrays together
so we have the first array 0 1 2 the
second array 3 4 5 and this is one way
you could do it the R 1 dot can can't
our array too but with the spread
operator there's a new way to do it
we're going to say that r1 equals we're
going to spread out the array 1 and
they're going to spread out the array 2
and then that's going to create a this
is going to concatenate the array 1 and
they're a 2
and if I just comment this out and you
can say 0 1 2 3 4 5 the great thing
about this is you can just actually add
more elements while you're while you're
concatenate them so let's just try that
example really quick and so you can
concatenate and add more elements and
you can if you want you can put the
second or a at the beginning the first
rate the end and it just gives a little
more flexibility than just to
concatenate Auk about the rest operator
like I said before the rest operator
looks exactly like the spread operator
is just three dots but it's basically
the opposite of the spread operator the
spread operator spreads or expands an
array into its elements but the rest
operator collects multiple elements and
condenses into a single array element
since it is an array you can use array
methods let me give you an example of
that so we have this function here
multiply we're gonna pass in two
arguments or is it more than two we're
gonna pass a multiplier and then we're
gonna pass in an argument that has the
rest operator right before the arms
since these three dots are being passed
in as an argument into a function that's
how we know that it's being used as the
rest operator and not the spread
operator so when we have the rest
operator and then we have the name of
called the ARBs we can actually pass in
as many arguments as we want into this
function so when we are passing in
things into this function the first
number we pass on will be the multiplier
and then everything else we passed in
will be condensed into an array called
the ARDS and then look what we're gonna
do here we're going to return the arms
dot map since it is an array you can use
array methods like map and we're going
to map each element to this we're going
to return multiplier times element
basically it's going to multiply each
and the arms by the multiplier so if we
have var array equals multiply to 1 2 3
so that's step function the first number
2 is the multiplier then 1 2 3 goes in
as an array an array containing 1 2 & 3
and now we're going to map each of this
1 2 3 into this math function we're
going to multiply each item 1 2 & 3 by
the first thing we passed in which is
the multiplier so if we run that you can
see at the end 1 2 & 3 have also all
been multiplied by 2 so we get 2 4 & 6
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good